I would say the audience was devastated
to hear about the passing of our beloved
wack Packer Fred the Elephant Boy Bobo
had some closing thoughts on Fred and
like most of Bobo I I you know I'm going
to be a little critical here again it's
clear he wrote this out it sounds Gary
what did you say about Bobo he sounds
like Luca Brazzi given the speech to uh
The Godfather it's all it's written out
and rehearsed yeah you know when that
famous speech that Luca Brazzi gives in
The Godfather and he goes you know I am
honored and grateful that you have
invited me to your daughter's wedding
on the day of your daughter's wedding
and I hope that their first child
be a masculine child
anyway here's Bobo in his best Luca
Brazzi delivering his two cents on Fred
the elephant he was a true legend among
Stern Nation I've grown to really like
him over the years I hung out with him
at wrestling events also AGT and other
events that were held I am very sad of
learning of his passing today
it just shows you time waits for nobody
look around every day taking the ocean
the lakes and be thankful for every
single day rest in peace Elephant Boy
you will be sorely missed it's the
greatest is that the greatest
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you guys don't understand this and
Gary you have to understand this you
always knock me down for this if you
don't write down your thoughts I'm gonna
lose them
every day Robin you should
always befriend a tree or look around
and wave at a blade oh Elephant Boy
we miss you he was a true legend
I am very sad
oh this is interesting on our phone is
high pitch Erica wants to say a few
words about elephant boy I wonder he did
have a a strained relationship didn't
they those two hated each other I know
Clinton and I
well I don't even remember why didn't
you like him again well he was saying
stuff about my mother Elephant Boy told
us before he died that he buried the
hatchet with Eric and that they had
called each other to make amends once
before he died is that true well after
after the People's Court we made them
out oh okay so
please and he will be missing
you know that and let me talk can I tell
you something about it is very sick
because they never called it Fred before
he passed me and Marianne tried to recap
the flag before he passed let me ask you
something why can't bobo be sad about
Elephant Boy why do you have to start a
new feud in other words okay Bobo yeah
go ahead I bought this not show respect
to Marianne as well at the Overstock
Marianne has done football though by the
way um Marianne is like The Godfather
you know
everyone's all worked up here now but
let me let me gotta stay on Marianne's
good side yeah yeah I mean we're hearing
you know hey we're hearing about
elephant boy and he's but Marianne he's
worried about Marianne what is going on
here well with uh oh I just think Eric
is very protective of me I think Volvo
calls him a few times in the past and he
thinks that I have I tell Eric not to
speak to him but that's not the truth
but really Howard I am so upset about
Fred because I did speak to him on his
birthday in November Gary knows his
radio has been turned off like by
accident Gary helped me get it back off
him because he really wanted to catch up
on the show and I I am truly truly
shocked that he's gone I called Fred
December 15th but he never answered and
I figured he lost his phone again not
knowing that Fred passed away and it's
shocking we're both the same age and
anybody who listened to the show fans of
course like even Balboa has his right to
to praise for uh you're right that's a
very nice eulogy there you go you know
and it wasn't written it was all off the
cuff there's a reason she's the mother
of The Wack Pack